my name is Leonard Austin and I'm the
CTO ravelin ravelin is a fraud detection
company we specialize in detecting
credit card fraud when a customer tries
to buy something from one of our
merchants the merchant will then
streamers all of that data and we will
use a load of machine learning behind
the scenes to try and analyze
transaction and make predictions around
whether that user is a genuine user or a
fraudulent user we consume a huge
quantity of data through our API it's
not just our clients real-time data but
it's also all of their historic data as
well it's everything from transactions
to customers orders along with all of
their transaction history and
potentially location data as well that's
typically terabytes of data per kleine
security is really important for us
because our clients are trusting us with
all of their data so we go to
extraordinary lengths to ensure that the
data that we hold is encrypted and
secure than close source projects cloud
security for us is better than on Prem
there's a lot of aspects to on Prem that
we just can't really facilitate and
Google can so on Prem has the problem of
having to manage your own security if we
had a warehouse of racks and data
centers we'd have to protect that
ourselves with the cloud we don't have
to do that so all of that is outsourced
to Google above and beyond that the
actual cloud itself and the way the
Google structures the file system means
that one file isn't stored on one
computer it's stored across multiple
disks which means even if someone was
able to get access to a particular disk
of physical access they wouldn't
actually be able to get any data from
that we migrated from another cloud
provider to GCP and the decision to move
to GCP wasn't taken lightly and we did a
lot of evaluation of GCP before deciding
to make the move one of the major
factors that made us think that it was
the right thing to do we could work with
our Account Manager and easily get
access to the documentation to prove to
our auditors that GCP was secure and he
was up to scratch the other thing that
we were able to do is work close to the
kms team and working with those guys you
could really see that there was a focus
and a road map that really took security
to the next
level there's a number of services that
GCP offered we couldn't get elsewhere
and examples like the identity aware
proxy which you can't get anywhere else
and encryption at rest by default but
also the further step that enables us to
supply encryption keys to Google so the
Google can't even an unencrypted the
data if they wanted to the identity of a
proxy for us is a really nice service
because it basically enables us to
protect all of our internal dashboards
without having the complicated set up
over VPN and having to get our users to
install VPN clients install credentials
have to factor or it's all baked into
the identity of a proxy and because
we're users of Google App Engine it just
means that there's no additional setup
for anyone within the company so those
are all really strong factors that
suggest that Google really cares about
security and it enables us to trust
Google with all of our data